I haven't been talking much about Milo
you nah police because I know there are
many people in our audience who don't
know who he is or they know and don't
really care to hear about him he's the
right wing all right
troll Trump supporter who's been going
on college tours he goes all over the
place sometimes he's welcomed by violent
protests which only helps to fuel his
popularity and his big thing is that as
a gay right winger who publicly talks
about how he likes dating black guys he
says the left isn't well prepared to
push back against him on identity since
he's an anti-feminist who also happens
to be a gay guy and he's a right winger
I've been in touch with him off and on
for several years here's the extent of
my contact with Milo years ago we were
scheduled to interview him about no no
topic other than online trolling and he
no call no Sh no showed and then the
next day or the day before he said that
he had been ill and just wasn't able to
tell me that he wasn't gonna make it on
the show and then more recently I
interviewed him about gamergate and we
talked about gamergate we also talked
about his views about how he thinks
transgenderism is a mental illness and
then more recently than that he sent out
some tweets before he was banned from
Twitter commenting about some of the
gamergate related interviews that I had
done okay that's the the full extent of
my contact with Milo you nopales he was
on Bill Maher over the weekend and it
Bill Maher received a ton of criticism
for even having him on journalists
Jeremy Scahill backed out of being on
that show because Milo innopolis was
going to be on and I'd say that I wasn't
opposed in principle to having Milo
yu-na police on the show I interview
people whose views I disagree with in
fine deplorable I had no problem
whatsoever with having him on I do think
Bill Maher did not do a great job of
confronting Milo's actual views on a lot
of issues and in fact Bill Maher was
sort of welcoming to Milo in ways that I
found a sort of a little bit odd I also
thought that Milo was strengthened pat
when two of the three panelists and Bill
Maher told Milo either fu or eff off
that those aren't arguments and I think
that that actually strengthened Milo's
position when P
just started swearing at him yeah that
was great to see I mean it was
interesting to see how Bill Maher and
meelo dealt with each other because I
think they do kind of agree on a lot of
points but because there was such a
circus around having him on the show I
think Bill Maher was more inclined to
defend him and you call him Neal oh
that's interesting I kind of like that
yeah I don't know how I thought you
maybe you're right maybe Milo is not
even the right way to pronounce it okay
so he shows up on Bill Maher this brings
a lot of attention to me low or my low
call him what you want and then people
start checking into what he said in the
past and a clip of Milo defending
effectively child rape and pedophilia
has gone completely viral and it has
caused some real problems for Milo in
Opelousas career it's from when he was a
guest on the drunken peasants podcast
about a year ago a show I appeared on a
couple of months ago I believe it was
and Milo spent a long time effectively
defending pedophilia saying that
attraction for adults to 13 year olds is
not necessarily a bad thing that he's
glad he had a sexual relationship with a
Catholic priest when he was a kid and
first he talks about will consent is
sort of arbitrary and generally speaking
yes there is an arbitrary nature to
consent is a 16 17 17 and a half 18 19
year old mature enough to have informed
consent about having sex with adults
okay you could you could have that
conversation but then it explodes from
there let's start with clip number one
I'm just gonna I'll be quick this
arbitrary an oppressive idea of consent
which totally destroys you know the you
know understanding that many of us have
the complexities and subtleties and
complicated nature of many relationships
you know people are messy and complex
and actually in a homosexual world
particularly some of those relationships
between younger boys and older men the
sort of coming of age relationships the
relationships in which those older men
have helped those young boys to discover
who they are and give them security and
safety and provide them with love and
and and and a reliable sort of a rock
where they can't sleep their parents
some of those relationships are some of
the most Asian to me
it sounds you know what it sounds like
Kathleen
molestation to me I'm grateful for
father Michael I wouldn't give nearly
such good head if it wasn't for him
keeps going on and on and defending
sexual relationships between adults and
thirteen year olds and he also says in
this appearance that sex between a
thirteen year old and a 38 year old is
actually okay that's the next clip we're
talking about 1325 1328 these things do
happen perfectly consensually often by
the way it's the women who suffer in
these because it's not what normally
happens in schools very often is this an
older woman with a younger boy and the
boy is the predator in that situation
sorry and he said 13 and 28 not 13 and
38 so first of all how is it consensual
when legally it's not someone who's able
to consent that that again is a legal
question Milo is going around saying
these clips have been selectively edited
but I listened to the entire section of
the podcast that doesn't seem like one
of those situations where more context
helps to excuse what Milo has said it
just all sounds bad and I hope the
audience will check it out but even what
I just played for you isn't really
defensible in any context and because of
all this Pat it's gotten bad CPAC has
rescinded their invitation for Milo to
speak at their conference he lost his
speaking gig effectively the the
American Conservative Union which runs
CPAC said we don't want him on stage
many of his upcoming college speaking
dates have been canceled he has this
book called dangerous that he was given
a 250 thousand dollar advanced on that's
now been cancelled and reportedly even
Breitbart is can reconsidering starting
to reconsider their relationship with
Milo I want to be super clear here this
video seems to have surfaced and gone
viral because of the appearance on Bill
Maher and people started paying
attention to that but some of his other
views are just as deplorable as what's
been pointed out here there are many
other reasons why you might want to say
oh we don't want Milo you knop Allah
speaking at our event and this has
nothing to do with suppressing free
speech or whatever people don't have a
right to speak at any event that they
want this seems to have gone viral but
there's plenty of horrible stuff in his
in his repertoire
yeah these comments have been out there
in the open for over a year now I mean
the drunken peasants have a large
following I even
watch this back about a year ago when it
aired and I mean it's really no surprise
this is kind of what he does he goes for
shock value he goes over the top and
sometimes that gets written off by him
as disingenuous later but you get caught
in saying these horrible things that's
gonna come back to bite you and he sort
of went the direction of oh I'm this was
like a Brit my British humour or
something like that he was just part of
a Facebook live thing that he did on on
Facebook yesterday all I would reiterate
is you know you guys know that I can
make edgy jokes you guys know that I can
sometimes push the boundaries of
acceptable humor this is one of those
cases in which I should have phrased
things differently and these videos from
a year ago and you and a half ago and I
really just had no idea I was I was
going to end up being this famous you
know late boozy long livestreams I
phrase things poorly and I enabled my
detractors and critics to assemble
material that looks very damning but
which does not reflect my what's
fascinating to me is that the right
claims to be against identity politics
particularly those based on sexual
orientation the right only became
interested in Milo you Napoles a British
guy of right I mean we're not even
talking about an American commenting on
American politics we're talk about a
British guy commenting on American
politics because of his identity as a
gay right winger his ideas were never
unique or particularly interesting
unless you say that they're interesting
because he is a gay conservative and it
turns out lo and behold Pat that it
wasn't a great idea for the right to
jump behind him because of the identity
politics that they claim to oppose yeah
and he also uses a defense that he did
this all in humor there was maybe one
joke in that entire clip and I guess he
has sometimes when you're making a joke
you get a pass on certain things but for
the most part I mean that was just him
speaking his mind yeah and you know he
said it was a Busey livestream or
whatever and that the phrasing was bad
maybe partially because he had been
drinking this reminds me of the Mel
Gibson thing right I mean no matter how
much alcohol I have I'm not going to
start saying homophobic things for
example because I don't hold those
beliefs Mel Gibson saying the alcohol
made me start saying anti-semitic stuff
well it was clearly in there somewhere
and I don't think it was an issue of
phrasing send me
thoughts about all this do you even care
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's episode is brought
to you in part by none other than blue
apron blue apron ships you the exact
amount of each ingredient for their
recipes that's required so you end up
not wasting food you can make
sustainable delicious home-cooked meals
in 40 minutes or less some of the meals
available in February include cashew
chicken stir-fry with Tango mandarins
and jasmine rice Sudan noodle soup with
miso and soft-boiled eggs I love me so I
admit that freely and crispy barramundi
with quinoa and roasted carrot salad
I actually am making the udon noodle
soup in a couple days looking forward to
it check out this week's menu get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron comm
slash Pakman that is PA que ma n you
will love how good it feels and tastes
to create home-cooked meals with blue
apron so don't wait
blue apron comm slash PA que ma n it is
a better way to cook